تعد شاشة غطاء galaxy z flip force
أكثر عملية وأكثر خصوصية بالنسبة
لك لأنه يمكنك تخصيص شاشة الغلاف
بصور متحركة على مدار الساعة أو
حتى مقاطع فيديو
، حيث يرسل فعل إغلاق الوجه
رسالة إلى من حولك بأنك
مستعد تمامًا  الانخراط في محادثة
[موسيقى]
ولكن عندما تحتاج إلى ذلك ، يمكنك
التحقق من الإشعارات على شاشة غلاف الوجه
دون مقاطعة اللحظة
التي تضيف الكثير من الراحة لروتيني اليومي ،
ويمكنني التحقق من الرسائل الجديدة والرد عليها
حتى أن شاشة الغلاف الخاصة بي تجعل الأمر سهلاً
ادفع مقابل فنجان من القهوة
سواء كنت تحجز رحلة طيران أثناء
مشاهدة مقاطع الفيديو أو المراسلة أثناء إجراء
مكالمة فيديو ، أصبحت تجربتك سلسة ، حيث
أردنا تحسين عمر
البطارية دون المساس بتصميم الوجه ،
فقد جعلنا المفصلة أقل نحافة أيضًا
مما وفر مساحة لـ  هذه
البطارية المحسّنة تمنحك شحنًا أطول
ستحتاج إليه لأننا نستخدم هواتفنا الذكية
كل يوم بعدة طرق ، فهي
تتمتع بنمذجة أكثر صلابة.  المفصلة
ومبيت الكاميرا الأكثر جرأة مقارنةً
بالموديلات السابقة ،
تأتي جالكسي زد فليب 4 الجديدة كليًا
بأربعة ألوان غير لامعة من الجرافيت الوردي
والذهبي والأزرق وأرجواني بورا المفضل لدينا ،
وقد وصل جالكسي زد فولد 4
[موسيقى]
يمكنك اللعب والدردشة على  في نفس الوقت
للحصول على المزيد من
شريط المهام للتجربة الاجتماعية على galaxy z fold 4 ، يساعدني التنقل
بسلاسة بين التطبيقات المختلفة ، مما يؤدي
إلى نقل تجربة تعدد المهام إلى مستوى آخر ،
وتأتي هذه الطية مع عدسة مقربة بدقة 10 ميجابكسل
مع تقريب بصري ثلاث مرات
وعدسة عريضة 50 ميجابكسل توفر
دقة محسّنة
Knightography هي أيضًا المستوى التالي مع
مستشعر أكبر يسمح بدخول المزيد من الضوء
مما يعني المزيد من الصور الرائعة لمشاهد السكين
والتي تكون أكثر سطوعًا بنسبة 23 بالمائة ،
لقد قمنا أيضًا بترقية تكبير الفضاء
حتى تتمكن الآن من رؤية ما تقوم بتصويره
دون أن تفقد مسار ما تريده.
إعادة تكبيري
[موسيقى]